mentors at the end of the day are
essential for us to advance
but i think most of us have a
misunderstanding of how mentorships
actually work
you can't
simply email somebody you respect and
say will you be my mentor for the same
reason you chat you can't just go up to
a stranger on the streets and say will
you be will you be my friend it doesn't
work like that
mentor relationships or relationships
like any others and if i think back to
the mentors how i met the mentors that i
have um they started off like
friendships where i was introduced to
them i liked them i guess they liked me
um and i called them up for some advice
and they took my call and i called them
up again and they took my call again
and then we went out for lunch and a
real friendship evolved
and they always seemed to have time for
me not because they were required to but
because they wanted to
and i remember i was leaving the house
of one of my mentors ron bruder and i
put my arm around him as i was saying
goodbye and i used the m word for the
very first time i said i'm really glad
you're my mentor and he said something
to me that i did not expect he said and
i'm really glad you're mine
and this is when i learned that great
mentor relationships both parties show
up to teach and both parties show up to
learn um and and though we may be the
advice givers some of the time the best
ones want to learn as much from their
mentees as they can give and in other
words it's a true friendship it's a
two-way street